a rising tide of Islamist militancy in
Africa is a growing threat to the US and
Europe there is a dangerous
misconception that African militant
groups are too locally focused or weak
to pose a real danger Africa is the next
front for the Salafi jihadi movement a
global ideological movement that
includes Isis and al-qaeda African
Salafi jihadi groups provide a local
base and source of resilience for these
organizations they are gaining strength
not because of ideological resonance but
because the spread of insurgencies and
conflict creates opportunities to
insinuate themselves in communities the
Trump administration is trying to do
more against these groups with increased
raids and drone strikes in places like
Somalia but it has still failed to
recognize the link between local
conflicts and grievances in the Salafi
jihadi movement these local issues
conflict and poor governance feel remote
and irrelevant to Americans and the task
of resolving them from Nigeria to Mali
to Libya to Somalia is large but
Americans must understand that
addressing these challenges now is far
cheaper than fighting yet another war
what's your take on American policy in
Africa
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI